blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman all right we are going to be
talking today about the pandora papers
much requested segment that'll be coming
up i want to start with facebook
instagram and whatsapp because yesterday
facebook and associated owned
apps and platforms whatsapp and
instagram
suffered a complete and total outage
their worst in a very long time
just hours after
a facebook whistleblower was revealed
and also made some
very very disturbing claims about
facebook's
uh awareness about negative influence on
people in society but putting according
to the whistleblower
profit over
uh society profit over people now are
the two stories connected rampant
speculation that the outage
was deliberately put in place by
facebook to prevent those very platforms
from being used to spread the claims
of the whistleblower the timing is
definitely interesting for sure there's
no denying it um although at this point
in time we don't have anything specific
that would tell us that that's what went
on some people are saying david what do
you need what do you need that's more
specific um let's look at the the two
stories sort of in tandem
first and foremost facebook
whistleblower revealed on 60 minutes
says the company prioritized profit over
public good would not come as a surprise
to many people that that's what facebook
did uh if indeed that is what the
um whistleblower observed the identity
of the facebook whistleblower who
released tens of thousands of pages of
internal research and documents leading
to a firestorm for the social media
company in recent weeks was revealed on
60 minutes sunday night as francis hagen
the 37 year old former facebook product
manager who worked on civic integrity
issues at the company says the documents
show that facebook knows its platforms
are used to spread hate
violence and misinformation and that the
company has tried to hide that evidence
reminds me of uh exxon mobil knowing in
the 70s the impact on the environment
that their drilling activity had
very similar vibes the thing i saw at
facebook over and over again
was there were conflicts of interest
between what was good for the public
and what was good for facebook and
facebook over and over again chose to
optimize for its own interests like
making more money hagen told 60 minutes
60 minutes correspondent scott pelly
quoted one internal facebook document as
saying quote we have evidence from a
variety of sources that hate speech
divisive political speech and
misinformation on facebook and the
family of apps
are affecting societies around the world
about a month ago hagen filed at least
eight complaints with the sec alleging
the company is hiding research about its
shortcomings from investors and the
public she shared the documents with the
wall street journal which published a
multi-part investigation showing
facebook was aware of problems with its
apps including the negative effects of
misinformation and the harm caused
especially to young girls by instagram
if you're interested in that
specifically check out some of jonathan
heights work on the effect of social
media
not just on young people in general but
disproportionately on young girls
something he's worked on quite a bit
haagen who started at facebook in 2019
is set to testify today before the
senate subcommittee on consumer
protection product safety and data
security i've seen a bunch of social
networks and it was substantially worse
at facebook than anything i've seen
before at some point in 21 i realized
i'm going to have to do this in a
systemic way that i'm going to have to
get out enough documents that no one can
question this is real facebook has
pushed back against reports claiming the
claims are misleading and arguing its
apps do more good than harm so we're
going to get back to that in a moment
simultaneously almost with the unveiling
of this whistleblower
facebook
suffering its worst outage since 2008
pulling down instagram pulling down
whatsapp as well
facebook instagram and whatsapp shut
down for more than six hours on monday
it marked the worst outage for the tech
giant since 2008 when a bug knocked
facebook offline for about a day but the
service had only 80 million users back
then
the outage was caused by quote
configuration changes on the backbone
routers
facebook's vp of infrastructure
santosh ginardin said in a blog post
late monday
as of the writing of this article some
of the services are not yet fully
functioning for example some users are
still reporting problems posting new
content to instagram all three platforms
stopped working shortly before noon when
websites and apps for facebook services
were responding with server errors
reports on downdetector.com showed the
outages appeared to be widespread okay
so
a bunch of interesting things here the
the first thing is again are these two
stories connected did is this a lie is
facebook just straight up lying
and they
pulled down access to their their
platforms
specifically to prevent prevent the
spread of the information about the
whistleblower
i don't know i mean you know this is one
of those things where there are people
who will say obviously not that's
obviously not what happened
others who will say of course that's
what happened this is an outage of this
degree is so rare
um that
the idea that it would just be a
coincidence is essentially impossible um
and then people with opinions in between
i don't know all i can tell you is the
timing is interesting now what was more
interesting is
that i missed nothing from these
platforms being down
and what i mean by that is okay i was
working i don't really do facebook
during the day
it didn't affect me negatively in any
way that facebook instagram and whatsapp
were down for this period of time now
maybe if it had been a saturday when i
might just be chatting with people on
some of these platforms maybe it would
have been different it did affect our
team we upload content to these
platforms we were unable to do so it
kind of threw for a loop our entire day
but it is very interesting to get
perspective sometimes on the importance
we believe that these apps have and then
what they really have when they are
missing now whatsapp is relied upon in
many countries as the default messaging
app
um and i am on a bunch of whatsapp
threads with people in other countries
argentina and elsewhere
obviously those weren't working i'm not
using that to communicate things of
paramount importance many people are and
it affected them significantly now
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
is using what happened yesterday as an
opportunity to say break these companies
up there's no reason whatsapp should
have to be down because facebook's down
other than facebook bought whatsapp
because it saw whatsapp as a competitor
we will deal with that on the bonus show
but in the meantime let me know your
thoughts do you see the outage and the
whistleblower unveiling as connected or
merely coincidental
now i want to get to some absolutely
mind-blowing audio this is like an
example of
some of the worst of the worst of
corporate response to a crisis
um npr's ari shapiro
interviewed interviewed interviewed
interviewed
neil potts facebook's vp for trust and
security yesterday about these documents
leaked by the whistleblower that was
exposed on 60 minutes or unveiled on 60
minutes
the interview is fascinating because
neil potts
doesn't really deny any of the claims
doesn't really deny any of the substance
of what the whistleblower alleges
but instead seems just sort of shaken
almost like he didn't expect these were
the questions that were going to be
asked he deflects using odd language
this is sort of a clinic
in not
in how not to do crisis management so
let's just jump right in and listen here
and facebook over and over again chose
to optimize for its own interests like
making more money we'll note that the
company is among npr's financial
supporters and we're joined now by
facebook executive neil potts he is vice
president for trust and safety welcome
to all things considered buckle up here
hey ari how are you
thank you all right good to have you
here uh so how can explain facebook's
calculus this way if the company changed
the algorithm to make people safer and
deprioritized hateful and divisive posts
then people would spend less time on the
site click on fewer ads the company
would make less money do you agree that
polarization leads to engagement which
translates to money for facebook so the
argument here it's important to
understand and i'm not going to keep
interjecting but the the idea here is
although facebook publicly says we want
to depolarize we want to remove
disinformation internally they know that
that stuff generates clicks which means
money so that in reality they say one
thing publicly but they encourage this
stuff on the platform to money for
facebook
i think i'll categorically deny that i
think that accusation is uh
just a bit unfounded at facebook what we
are designing our products to do is to
increase it
increase meaningful experiences so
whether those are meaningful social
interactions i think that is the the
change that uh the leaker mentions in
her 60 minutes interview um or having
just positive social experience on a
platform that is what we want the
products ultimately to provide now it's
not unfounded in that there are
thousands of documents that the leaker
provided which show the opposite of what
neil potts is saying
environment where people will come to
facebook where they will come to
instagram and have a just a better time
and that's really our bottom line so i
just want to be clear are you saying it
may be the case that polarization leads
to more engagement but we're not trying
to polarize our users so that's not what
we want the algorithm to do or are you
saying no the premise that more extreme
views will lead people to engage more is
just fundamentally wrong
i think just taking a step back on on
that question of polarization i think
polarization has you know existed long
before facebook so that's a deflection
okay the question is really specific and
and and neil pot says we didn't create
polarization that wasn't the question
neil this long after um perhaps or that
we're all
no longer here that being said at
facebook we're not designing anything to
be uh for the sensational or click-baity
or engagement baby ways that
polarization um
may be seen and that i think was being
accused of facebook in the leadership
the guy's making absolutely no sense i
mean it just seems completely unprepared
for what were obviously going to be the
questions on the product our products
are designed to have more meaningful
social interactions those interactions
with your friends your loved ones what
does that mean close-knit groups can
ensure that you're coming to the
platform to have a just a positive
social experience one that you can have
not only just meaningful experiences but
things that you will find perhaps
unfettered
on positive
values in
you guys i hope everybody realizes this
guy's making no sense and answering none
of the questions specifically about some
of the safeguards that were put in place
after in the run-up to the 2020 election
um these were to reduce misinformation
and haugen says many of those
protections went away after the election
we now see indictments against some of
the january sixth rioters that cite
facebook posts so how does facebook
descend defend its decision to dissolve
its civic integrity unit now that you
know what happened
just after the election when some of
those safeguards were no longer in place
beautiful
thanks sorry i think
i want to make sure that we're very
clear here the pacific integrity unit
has not been dissolved in any ways
actually it has been uh in many ways
promoted throughout the company the team
is now sitting with other teams so that
we can take the lessons learned so this
was a centralized team and now its
individual responsibilities have been
farmed out to other teams
it's still within our centralized
integrity uh
i don't know that this guy says one
thing that we can actually take away
that's substantive the broader team to
focus on other issues including civic
integrity but also issues that so it's
like what he's saying is the team we had
has not actually been disbanded it's
just been broken up and they're now
distributed
and working on different issues well so
you've disbanded it right the the people
have been separated and they're working
on different issues and maybe also this
one issue issues that are i think at the
top of everyone's mind including uh
issues around health and in covet 19.
you can see a lot of the similarities
between the way that we treated
elections on the platform with our
elections hub as well as what we are
doing around cove at 19 in the coca-19
hub so those teams are still
in practice doing work and actually
working on civic issues and elections
the teams are still in practice doing
work
let me turn to instagram and how it
affects young people here's how haugen
characterized the company's research
last night on 60 minutes facebook's own
research says
it is not just that instagram is
dangerous for teenagers that harms
teenagers
is that it is distinctly worse than
other forms of social media and she says
that research found 13.5 percent of teen
girls said instagram makes thoughts of
suicide worse 17 said it worsened eating
disorders and when congress asked about
this ceo mark zuckerberg misstated the
company's research and then withheld the
damaging information that came out in
this league how does facebook justify
that
i think mark withheld any of the
research i think one of the issues here
we're very committed to doing research
we recognize the values so we can close
the gaps we're reducing gaps but i want
to put a bit of the context of this
research um
in the field as well
it just goes absolutely we're committed
to doing research to close gaps yeah but
that's not what the question was about
uh this research was done over a
for boys and girls of teenage years over
12 different areas and the majority
actually the majority of respondents
here both boys and girls so that
facebook has facebook and instagram
having that positive on their okay and
of course that's also a deflection
because the point is
many things for most people aren't
negative but if something is negative
for a lot of people it still matters and
it's still important so neil potts not
prepared
answering nothing of substance and we're
going to continue to follow what the the
the
um fallout is from this uh both from the
outage and from the whistleblower i want
to remind you tuesday october 19th at 6
pm eastern we'll be doing a david pakman
show live town hall it will be
exclusively streamed on the new david
pakman show youtube channel pacman live
which you can find at youtube.com slash
pacman live get subscribed there in
advance of the live town hall
find me on twitter let me know what you
think about this facebook stuff i'm i'm
at deepakman on
twitter one of our sponsors is blinkist
who's been supporting the david pakman
show longer than any other sponsor
blinkist is the app that lets you listen
to or read an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes
blinkist is the way to absorb those
books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
many of you have been emailing me about
the pandora papers and i want to start
and do sort of like a brief overview of
what the pandora papers are
and um kind of show you how i would go
through learning about what is here now
one completely reasonable way to start
would be go directly to
the source material which we're going to
do i'm actually for this particular
segment i'm going to start with the wiki
article about the pandora papers now a
lot of people will say david anybody can
edit wikipedia it's not actually a
source and wikipedia would admit that
wikipedia you have to source the things
that are there although there are
inaccuracies in wikipedia in this
particular article i actually think that
it's a good place to start to get an
overview of what this is about then we
go to primary sources then we go to
articles about it so what are the
pandora papers the pandora papers are
11.9 million leaked documents
that were published by the icing the
international consortium of
investigative journalists starting on
october 3rd two days ago
the leak exposed the secret offshore
accounts of 35 world leaders including
current and former presidents prime
ministers and heads of state
as well as more than 100 billionaires
celebrities and business leaders the
news organizations of the icij described
the document league as their most
expansive expose of financial secrecy
yet containing documents images emails
and spreadsheets from 14 financial
service companies in nations including
panama switzerland and the arab emirates
surpassing their previous release of the
panama papers in 2016. at the time of
the release of the papers the icij said
it is not identifying its source
up to an estimated 32 trillion u.s
dollars excluding non-monetary valuables
such as real estate art and jewelry
may be hidden from being taxed according
to news reports now just to hear
there are 12 different citations that we
could look at
okay
the next part is about disclosures
there's a sub article a list of people
named in the pandora papers which you
can look at separately it lists heads of
state and it goes from
the king of jordan abdullah ii
through you know the chilean president
the kenyan president it includes former
heads of state as well
heads of government
um
including patrick achi the prime
minister of cote d'ivoire
and many others heads of organizations
ministers bankers some of these
individual names will be meaningful to
people some less so
royalty including the former king of
spain juan carlos
business people on and on and on so we
now have sort of like an initial
understanding of what this is these are
disclosures
about the financial holdings assets and
accounts
of important or elite individuals where
do we go next next we go to the actual
disclosures on the website of the
international consortium of
investigative journalists
this is filled with various articles and
different documents
many of these start to be sort of
commentaries on
the pandora papers but one thing you can
go to is the key findings section from
the organization that put this together
itself the key findings are and again
we're just we're building our
understanding of what this is an
investigation by more than 600
journalists from 150 news outlets has
unearthed offshore dealings of 35
current and former world leaders and
more than 300 other current and former
public officials and politicians the
offshore system continues to thrive
despite decades of legislation
investigations and international
agreements aimed at combating money
laundering and tax dodging
south dakota and more than a dozen u.s
states have become leaders in the
business of selling financial secrecy
even as the u.s blames smaller nations
for enabling tax avoidance and dirty
money flows that's important you know
very often it's believed that if you
want to do tax avoidance and shield
assets you go to the caribbean
uh you go to switzerland etc but
actually south dakota and some other
states have become really uh nexuses or
nexi
in this uh um apparatus
the pandora papers unmask the hidden
owners of offshore companies secret bank
accounts private jets yachts mansions
and artworks by picasso banksy and other
masters the biggest lick
the biggest lick the biggest leak in
icij history contains almost three
terabytes of information from 14
offshore service providers so then you
could go and look at the actual data if
you wanted
um this is another part of the website
which at this immediate moment is not
loading once we've done this
then you can certainly look at other
commentaries and summations of the
pandora paper so for example bbc
has put out a guide to the leak that
focuses on
uh the uk
right the owners of more than 1500 uk
properties bought using offshore firms
the qatari ruling family who avoided 18
and a half million pounds tax on a
london super mansion
uh the prominent tory donor involved in
a european corruption scandal and it
goes on and on from there so this is how
i would get myself informed and
obviously i would probably spend
an hour looking at this stuff we don't
we're not going to do an hour because
that would be the whole show but that's
how i would start take a glance at the
wiki
to understand what this is generally
about
look at those citations
go to the primary reporting and then
expand into commentaries about the
social implications the cultural
implications the economic implications
we'll dive deeper on specific aspects of
this over the coming week but that can
serve as a sort of initial introduction
to what these leaks are
um i want to talk about
in all seriousness
this is sort of one of the better
interviews i've seen
with donald trump
um thanks to the interviewer adam
shapiro from yahoo finance not a guy i
was familiar with that that at least i
remember ahead of this interview
adam shapiro did a 22 minute long
interview with donald trump
it's absolutely horrifying for donald
trump but adam shapiro actually makes a
real attempt to get trump to answer the
questions that he's asking and to ins
insist by asking again when trump goes
elsewhere it still unhinged trump
but adam shapiro was actually able to
sort of get trump to weigh in on certain
things uh let's start with a clip the
topic is 2024 how in well how and when
would trump decide what does he think
about the possible challenge faced uh
that he faces from ron desantis the sort
of trumpian to the extreme governor of
florida um a lot of different questions
here let's just jump right into it so mr
trump i i when you consider what it's
going to take for you to decide if
you're going to run for president this
would be one of the issues curious
though there would be one who would just
agree with just confidence yeah one of
many issues i would imagine but but
you'd have to win the nomination yeah by
the way trump trump already just talking
over adam shapiro not even letting him
get to the it is true it's typical trump
but adam shapiro really does a pretty
good job here
i'm curious how would you i'll give you
a couple of other economy inflation how
would you how would you
if you faced a republican like ron
desantis in the primaries how what would
it take for you to beat him yeah well
number one i don't think i will faze him
uh because i don't see that if i if i
did it i don't see that i think most
people would drop out i think he would
drop that and if i faced him i'd beat
him like i would beat everyone else so
this is interesting because trump is
saying
he believes if he ran
a lot of people would drop out either
out of respect to trump or for whatever
that's interesting to hear
and you take a look at what's going on
in the polls
where i have way over 90 and in some
cases 98 approval rating in the
republican party because i did it i did
a great job as president despite all of
the hoaxes despite the russia russia
russia now it's not completely true what
trump is saying um trump is dominating
the primary field for 2024
um but his approval is less relevant
than the number who say they would vote
for him to be the nominee and that's
about 58 it's a high number it's still
the highest number anybody else has
uh but it is not you know trump by
saying 90 or whatever is acting like he
would get uh 90 of the primary vote he
he may well have 80 or 90 approval
though he never really cites sources
he's polling in between 50 and 60 in
terms of the actual primary that now has
been exposed as a total fraud despite
everything we did a great job largest
tax cuts in history rebuilt the military
space force took care of our vets 92
approval rating in the va for the first
time ever
way higher than ever before you know we
did
a job that nobody's done and had
coveted not coming interrupted we had
the greatest economy again
say what you want we had 160 million
jobs our country was never close to that
now of course we've talked before about
the labor participation rate sort of
hoaxes the population of the u.s grows
and so most of the time we have more
people working than ever before or close
to it and more people not working than
ever before or close to it that's just a
political game that they play it's
inevitable
mr trump it's not what i want it's just
the the jobs created uh during your
administration i think that it's the
bureau of labor statistics points out it
was something like 6.4 million jobs and
during the obama administration it was 7
million jobs but when i hear what you're
saying about the need for perhaps you to
run in 2024 what i'm hearing you say is
you are going to run are you
no i haven't i haven't said that i said
that if i do run
i think that i'll do extremely well and
i'm looking not only at polls i'm
looking at the enthusiasm we did a great
job now when you say
what you had just said the economy as
you know was very bad when he took over
so uh the economy wasn't terrible when i
took over but it wasn't great it was
stagnant that slow i guess it was the i
guess it was the worst recovery since
the depression of 1930. okay so trump
getting into his very strange and random
kind of historical claims but the truth
is uh the economy was generally good
under trump until covet hit there was
job creation under trump but the the
rate of job creation diminished compared
to under obama and trump got lower job
creation with a significantly higher
deficit so we can analyze that for what
it is but let's make sure we're actually
analyzing the real data next trump goes
on to i'm sorry adam shapiro moves on to
steve bannon where there seems to be a
disagreement bannon says he talks to
trump regularly trump's like no i don't
talk to the guy i haven't talked to him
for a long time mr trump there's one
last question i want to ask you as we
wrap and it's because i covered your
administration for the first year and a
half i was in washington and i remember
that steve bannon lost your trust when
he spoke to michael wolff for that book
and he left the administration but he's
re-earned your trust and i'm curious
what he did to get back into your good
graces and to get your trust yes
well steve didn't get along with certain
people in the administration so i
understand that that happens and it
happens with all administrations frankly
and
for a period of time
he didn't just didn't do it and i
understand that but if you look at steve
over the last three years he sees what a
great job we've done as an
administration when you look at all of
the things that i've enumerated plus
many others i mean i think like no this
is not an answer to the question notice
but but eventually adam shapiro jumps in
with what is the real question
where you can get
uh medical treatment of something
experimental if you're in a bad shape
he was advising you towards the end of
your administration
excuse me mr bannon was advising you
towards the end of the administration no
not at all no i haven't spoken to steve
uh almost at all no he wasn't but i know
that he's got a show that's very
successful he says he does
so is he lying when he says he was
talking to you uh in the last months of
your administration
very little we would speak very little
now stephen i spoke very little but uh i
will tell you he was very supportive so
someone is lying certainly uh but now
trump backing off by saying we spoke
very little which makes it you know
maybe mildly plausible one last clip
here's donald trump asked about
cryptocurrency it's just kind of
interesting a great many of our viewers
here on the yahoo finance platform are
into cryptocurrencies and the well-known
bitcoin investor anthony pompliano was
just on my program talking about china's
crackdown on crypto he says that's a big
gain for the united states you have a
relationship with the chinese president
xi jinping what do you think xi jinping
is up to and is this crackdown on crypto
good for the u.s
well i think he wants to do his own
currency uh whether it's crypto or
otherwise and one of the reasons that
we have to be very careful is we have a
currency right now the dollar
and i'm a big fan of the dollar i'm a
big fan of our currency and i don't want
to have other currencies coming out and
hurting or demeaning the dollar in any
way and china's looking to do uh
china's certainly not looking to back
the dollar but right now they're based
on the dollar and they would probably
have to stay that way unless we do
something very foolish in our country so
we what the takeaway here is trump
really doesn't know what he's talking
about but i liked the interview in that
the interviewer
prevented trump from going totally off
the rails he kept trump focused enough
where you could tell trump doesn't
really understand these issues in any
kind of serious way very
overall very nice job there by adam
shapiro and yahoo finance that interview
not getting a lot of views at all some
of those clips only have 5 000 views on
the yahoo finance channel worth looking
at in total we'll have more clips on the
show's instagram at david pakman show
find us there
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
today i am joined by james cromwell
actor activist producer whose new film
mondo hollywoodland follows a
politically confused mushrooms dealer
who traverses through hollywood
available now on amazon prime video
james so great to have you on i really
appreciate it thank you so
talk to us a little bit about this this
film which you produced um what what was
the genesis of the idea here
uh the genesis of the idea was that uh
maybe it made him easier for him to sell
the film
i love the honesty i love it
which matters a lot which matter it's
not a small issue no it is not not if
you want your film to be seen
um can you talk a little bit about the
60s era mondo films that that this movie
is sort of an homage to
um and and sort of what you see is
interesting about the the
genre
well i i think uh if i if i have my
genres right it's a new velvag um
it's uh gadard and chebral and varda and
truffaut
the new wave they called it
i think of this film sort of a sabuta
suf which is goddard's film only in
color
there were
there are stories that goddard actually
knew
that what he was doing was bad but that
was the whole point
so he was trying to look at the language
of film
uh and develop a new syntax a new way of
making films sort of the way bertold
breck does with what it's called ver
fremdom's effect which is to distance an
audience to keep them aware that it is
filmic that it is a film it is a fiction
it is a narrative it relates
to something that is up for the audience
to create for themselves in in hearing
you talk in in this way about films
i'm sort of
i'm realizing and i wonder if you agree
that this type of analysis of film has
become
sorely lacking sort of in popular
culture in the united states at this
point in time uh do you agree with that
i mean it's it seems to me that the
richness of the discussion of film
um in this style is not what it once was
in in popular society
certainly in america yeah because in
america film is considered a product
a studio has a certain pro studio works
is owned by a corporation that
corporation has obligations to its
shareholder to produce a profit they
produce
this thing called a film cinema
they show the cinema and they try to
reach as broad an audience as possible
so they either play down to that
audience or through the media that they
also control they create reviews that
make the thing seem as vacuous as
possible right so let's not send anybody
before they they're sitting in the seats
watching it so there's two layers in
other words the film is created in a
certain way
but the discussion of that film and its
promotion could still be more
substantive but even that in order to
make the film appealing is is kept
relatively superficial so you really
have two layers of this that you're
fighting against
yeah if you think of a film like joker
and you think well are they gonna take
are they gonna take that film seriously
uh you know some people um
which i'm really glad were offended by
that film but there's a lot to unpack in
that film there's a lot of discussions
about who we are where we are what we're
doing are we insane
um
who runs the show
uh what can we do as individuals to
oppose it uh what is the cost of living
in a dysfunctional society when your
entire mental
structure is uh is cobbed together from
falsehood
i remember uh watching an interview
where charlie rose interviewed the late
david foster wallace and they were just
chatting about different things and
charlie rose asks david foster wallace
his opinion about the english patient
and after sort of in that that david
foster wallace sense of saying you
really care what i think about the
english patient is that real do you are
you really asking me that he says i
think it's
a beautifully filmed
commercial hollywood endeavor that was
sort of like his top line analysis that
fundamentally it's still it it looks
nice but it's a profit driven hollywood
endeavor
is is your top line analysis of a film
similar where first you're you're
looking at what what was the point of
the production here was it an
independent project was a profit driven
project hollywood etc
uh that that enters into my thinking um
also the way that certain
um what would i call them um
not metaphors but when they use
contemporary situations circumstances
events that really happened or real
people exploitatively without examining
what they're doing they just use it
because it it gives a patina of reality
of of pertinence
um
and i think it's a great mistake people
do that with the with the holocaust they
do that with the uh the nazis they do
that in a variety of ways the politics
are always what it comes down to is it's
basically a boy meets girl boy loses
girl boy gets girl
but so a film like siriana which has
many many many many many many layers
yeah and it's very provocative if you
think about it gets short shrift because
they know
the powers that be is that an audience
is not going to be able to analyze that
film from
an understanding of the what the reality
is so they'll miss half the film and say
what was that all for i don't understand
i like george clooney he's so funny why
can't he do and you think wow that's uh
that's a waste it's so interesting that
that that you mentioned that movie
because that's one that i've thought
about in this context where when you
look at the analysis and the discussion
of it
it it's it's talking about 20 or 30 of
the film and and like you're pointing
out there's so much substance there that
seems to be above the radar in a sense
or below i don't know
yeah i agree um when it comes to
you mentioned
the holocaust for example as as one uh
uh topic sometimes that's touched in
certain ways and not others i just
finished up reading the book technopoly
by the critic neil postman where he
talks about in the education context in
the united states and this book was
written in 1992 but still relevant
there's often agreement about what are
valuable topics in school and the
holocaust is one that is considered we
teach about the holocaust we teach about
slavery etc similarly in in literature
there are often
books or authors where there's a sort of
consensus like it's important that
students read this
but less commonly is there really
thought
given to
what is it that we want people to learn
and then how should they
use this in their lives going forward
like what's the point what do we want
people to take away from learning about
the holocaust or whatever the case may
be is that
uh
applicable to film as well when some of
these
events or ideas are used just to make a
move a movie excuse me
yes i think i think it is um um i did a
film uh
uh
called the um panama papers i think it
was called the papers
and uh
it was interesting because the
panama papers revelations
it seemed to exclude every american
there was no american mention
and there's no real connection to an uh
there was a an event in america but it
was the the uh it wasn't central to what
the story was about which was how this
uh catastrophe uh occurred and i know
i'm noticing the same things in this new
revelation the pandora papers
that it's all about kenyatta of of kenya
and somebody in czechoslovakia
and all these people then they say and
celebrities and i don't know what the
that consortium of uh independent
journalists thought was happening with
people who have a great deal of money
because that's what they do
they make very clear that there's no
um
there's no criminality involved but at
the same time they don't show you the
whole story which is two of our states
delaware and
um
south dakota are are probably two of the
biggest offshore uh deposits of
um people's money uh that there are yeah
so so in other words in almost any time
you film is a very simple medium
if you overlay it with a lot of fact if
there's a lot of levels to understanding
it's very hard to keep an audience
because an audience is only interested
not only in the narrative but seeing
themselves in the character so that they
can experience the thing that the things
that the character does and they play
this sort of game isolated by themselves
whereas you get a film like the battle
of algiers which i saw back in the 60s
in a movie house in new york and uh
there were black panthers out in the
front row right right in front of me and
of course they understood every nuance
of that film because they'd seen it in
their community but i a nice white boy
sitting behind him i'm looking at this
film it's revelatory but i know nothing
about
how the police how the state operates in
a ghetto to suppress the aspirations of
the people
right
um a couple of things i wanted to ask
about may be related to this you've been
arrested several times doing activism
it's typically like trespassing basic
civil disobedience
does that have any long-term impact in
any kind of legal sense do those arrests
matter because they're not they don't
rise to the level interestingly enough
of where you start falling subject to
like a three strikes and you're out sort
of thing does it have any impact at all
on you well actually it does in texas
um the one i have in texas i'm still on
probation wow
means that i cannot i get arrested in
any state for breaking any law
um and
you know it
if i
had a larger um
a career i suppose that i would be like
uh
some
wonderful people in hollywood who
actually do do really great work
i'm not sure that sean penn
uh gets the opportunities to do the work
now that he did before
because of the work that he did in haiti
and the enemies that he made in haiti uh
namely the clinton foundation and um
and the united nations and what he saw
and how he reacted to it and how he
spoke about it so
i i don't know um my activism i don't
think raises to that rises to that level
but people do notice
uh and um
it is a valid tech it is a technique of
civil disobedience
uh breaking the law in order to bring
attention to the law
uh to to crimes that are being being
committed inside of the law
um and uh there will be ramifications to
my career there may be but i i can't
stop it i have to continue doing what
i'm doing no doubt no doubt um you were
a bernie supporter are you what's your
sense so far of joe biden's uh
presidency
how many haitians has he set back
how what's he doing at the border
what's he what listen it's almost the
same with obama obama had both both
houses of congress
he had the presidency he did absolutely
squat
i don't think much changes between that
administration and what it managed to
accomplish since it until it got into
the sort of stalemate that's going to
exist in 2022 when the republicans take
back the house we're going to be in the
same bloody position
it the change as
as
um
toonberry says and other young
environmentalists say
it's not going to come from the blah
blah blah of politicians it's going to
come from the street it's going to come
from the demands of people and uh
i think
i think that will happen so you don't
think too highly so far of what of what
joe biden has done clearly do you do you
distinguish between
is there consequence to the fact that
it's joe biden and not another four
years of trump
it's not another four years of trump but
we all in the 60s we also say yeah but
it's so much is so much like it under
the surface i mean when you watch the
policies what's happening around the
world what when are we going to start
it looks like we're trying to start a
war with china but what's going to
happen
around the world to this war state that
we have created to
satisfy the needs of the
military-industrial complex we need
those wars we need those bases i just
watched the film on the f-35 the f-35
the development of the f-35 is going to
cost
over 1 trillion
between 1 and point seven trillion
dollars they're they're being sold at
180 million dollars a piece what what
are we doing as we head towards the
precipice of environmental destruction
what are we doing
supporting this industry those
industries and
the extraction industries
so he's open he just opened up a whole
new drilling thing off the coast of off
the west coast after they had that oil
spill caused by a ship dragging its
anchor and puncturing a pipe yeah
there's no way to have
this system and i by that the system i
mean capitalism
have a democratic solution to the
problems that all the problems that heal
us
the environment racism sexism
across the lot nothing is going to
change as long as people put profit
ahead of people do you see the systems
in places like denmark norway and sweden
as sufficiently different or is that not
enough
no
i think it's sufficiently different
it's not a no it's not enough it needs
to be reexamined however if we had the
system of the scandinavian countries we
could at least have a dialogue about
what's happening in this country right
what's happening to the people who feel
so disaffected that they attacked the
congress of the united states violently
to achieve what
they their lives were not appreciably
made better by that man's
presidency so what what are they
thinking are they thinking or are they
being led by an australian named murdoch
to not be able to distinguish the truth
from falsehood when it's right in their
faces and it's them yeah
he's the worst
he's up there for sure he is up there
for sure yeah we've been speaking with
actor and activist james cromwell the
new film is mondo hollywoodland
james i so appreciate being able to
speak with you the film is now available
on amazon prime video and we're linking
to it uh real really a pleasure speaking
with you today
likewise enjoy the film it's really a
wonderful film see it
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show we have major
controversial vaccine news from the
state of california which has announced
that california will require
eligible students in public
and private schools
to be vaccinated against covid19 now the
real headline should be
california will require eligible
students in public and private schools
to be vaccinated against covid19
in addition to all the other vaccines
that california students in public and
private schools already have to be
vaccinated against that because that's
really what this is california already
has a long list of requirements and
importantly they apply to private
schools as well
looking at an article from abc 7
california will soon require all
students in both public and private
schools to get the covid vaccine once
it's authorized by the fda for different
age groups
gavin newsom announced the emergency
order friday while visiting a middle
school in san francisco the covet
vaccine will now join a list of 10 other
vaccinations required for children to
attend school in the state
the governor said the state will issue
the mandate in the next school term
following the fda's approval the
earliest being january 122 and the
latest being july 1 of 2022 the
government has fully approved the
vaccine for those 16 plus but only
emergency use for 12 to 15 once that
group is fully approved the state will
require students in 7th through 12th
grades to get vaccinated california will
require it for students in kindergarten
through 6th grade after that approval
takes place
at the same time staff members at all
state schools will need to be fully
vaccinated the state issued a mandate in
august for teachers and school staff now
it has eliminated the option to do
regular testing instead of getting the
vaccine you just got to get the vaccine
students would be granted religious and
medical exemptions but the rules for how
does the state would apply them have not
yet been written any student who refuses
to take the vaccine will be forced to do
independent study courses at home
very important in california
um
it also applies to charter schools and
it also applies to private schools
charter and private schools are held to
the same standards and same curriculum
requirements and it applies to vaccines
as well that's not the case in all
states that's how california is
organized
california already requires 10 vaccines
to go to school
there are some anti-vaxxers who complain
about that but not many so this is
relatively uncontroversial and once you
understand existing california law with
regard to vaccination and exemptions
california has also really tamped down
on religious exemptions for vaccinations
medical is one thing but religious
they've uh very much tamped down on you
realize that there is really not much
controversy here
relative to the existing california law
now if you live in a state that is
completely different laws
what's happening in california might
sound shocking it still shouldn't be it
might be very much incongruous with
what's happening in your state but for
california law
completely normal expected and we're
going to be hearing more about it very
soon
i have an example for you today
of totally backwards morality and
bankrupt principles they're not even
really principles quite frankly fox news
anchor martha mccallum
bemoaned
a free lunch program in new jersey
saying there are kids who might grow up
thinking
school lunch is actually free can you
guys imagine can you imagine if a kid
grew up thinking school lunch is free it
would be terrible
for them everybody i guess let's listen
to martha mccallum this is like the
worst of the worst of this strict father
morality ideology that we hear espoused
by uh some on the right and certainly on
fox news listen to this
one of the things that kills me is that
now that you know there's a free lunch
program in new jersey and it's for
everyone even if you you don't need help
to send your child's lunch to school so
those kids are all gonna grow up
thinking well school is lunch is free
right and then god help the person who
comes along and tries to take that away
larry you talk about free lunch i mean
that that will never once that happens
right once it's baked in there it's
never gonna but it's important what you
said
you're gonna pay for it with higher
taxes and higher inflation and i think
most again
common sense americans know this is not
right they don't want big government
socialism they don't want a welfare
state worker can you imagine so
first of all martha
seems sympathetic to whoever is going to
try to stop the free school lunch now
there's a couple different things here
how is it that we have public education
paid for through taxes it's like prepaid
in a sense it's not free it's prepaid
public education but not the lunch
you add the lunch and now it's socialism
idiotic i mean the level on which these
people operate is is absolutely pathetic
but why shouldn't school lunch be free
and again in a literal sense the food's
not free but people pay property taxes
to fund schools people pay property
taxes for a lot of things there are some
parts of the country it's municipality
based in some parts of the country your
property taxes include trash and
recycling pickup it's part of your
property taxes we don't say it's free we
say it's prepaid through property taxes
in some parts of the country i have
relatives who live in municipalities
where property taxes don't include trash
pickup you've got to do your property
taxes and then you've got to hire
someone you know it could be 30 bucks a
month whatever
to do your trash pickup and your
recycling pickup in either case is this
is anything free sometimes it's just
included sometimes property taxes pay
for good schools sometimes the property
taxes people pay pay for not so good
schools if property taxes cover school
lunch
what's the big realization that's going
to be devastating for kids just oh
the property taxes cover school lunch
also school is mandatory you have to be
there but they don't have to give you
food at no additional cost remember it's
not free
it's paid for through property taxes
you you have it it's not free at point
of purchase to have food when you're
obligated to be in school
they're uh uh there are kids who are
depending on school in order to eat by
the way i think it's important to
mention um is it a good thing for kids
to be thinking
that whether or not they have food that
day depends on all of this other stuff
other than just did you come to school
today great you get lunch and remember
it's not really free
it's prepaid that to be accurate it's
prepaid through property taxes
uh you know my mom didn't charge me for
lunch at home
but i didn't think it was free i
realized she bought the food
my dad bought the food right um imagine
thinking that so-called free school
lunch is the problem
and not the financially
and not the fact that huge corporations
sometimes pay zero taxes despite
profiting handsomely handsomely uh just
such a backwards world and the disdain
the indignant martha mccallum can you
imagine god help she says
god help kids who think they grow up
thinking that school lunch is is free
this is a huge part of the problem
ideologically in this country where we
end up having to
put energy and time into these debates
when we could all just agree like hey
school lunch being prepaid through
property taxes it's no big deal let's
focus on something better let's improve
education
and by the way if you're hungry at
school you're not going to learn you're
not going to learn so there's a number
of different ways in this in which this
just makes absolutely perfect sense we
have a voicemail number which is 219 to
david p you can call anytime if you have
a message for me this caller admits to
voting for kirsten cinema previously
and says she's ashamed for having done
it take a listen
hi david this is barb from tucson
arizona
and i am ashamed to say i personally
voted for kristin cinema when she ran
last time because she represented
herself as being a democrat which she
apparently is not she's just an
attention getting brat stomping her feet
and i'll tell you this i have personally
contacted the county democratic
headquarters and requested that they
start a recall petition we need to get
rid of her yeah you know the the uh i
appreciate the caller for being honest
and uh being honest about her shame
um i actually i know arizona has recalls
for legislators it has a mechanism
i can't tell from looking at it at
whether it only applies to state
legislators or whether it would apply to
a representative in dc like kirsten
cinema i don't see it as likely and you
know why
cinema is still pretty popular in
arizona i know there's a lot about she's
just horrible and everybody hates her
federally she's not very popular in
arizona those are the folks who get to
vote
she's really not doing that poorly
and so i i don't know whether that
recall would work but there are lots of
folks like this caller who say i did
vote for her but i wouldn't next time
and uh we'll see what the future holds
for kirsten cinema we're going to talk
on the bonus show today about major
decisions upcoming for the supreme court
on guns on abortion on death penalty
as the approval of the death penal of
the uh uh supreme court rather is lower
than it's been in decades we will also
talk about congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez's
pouncing on facebook and saying break
facebook up
in the wake of the major outage that
took uh place yesterday which affected
facebook as well as instagram and
whatsapp which we talked about at the
top of the show
and we will talk about lars vilks the
muhammad cartoonist from 2007 he has
died
in a car accident um
we will talk and and review the entire
muhammad cartoon story all of those
stories on today's bonus show get
instant access by signing up at
joinpacman.com we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com
david pakman